i'm [ __ ] teloza and at the mcgovern  institute i use computer models to study  the brain  when i was in middle school i put  together my first computer out of spare  components we had lying around the house  i was really into video games and wanted  to play on my own pc  video games are actually why i first got  into programming  i wanted to change the rules of those  virtual worlds to fit my imagination i  would spend hours trying to reverse  engineer how little  simple snippets of code interacted with  each other to make the characters on the  screen behave the way they did  it's really not that different from what  i do now i build computer models to try  to understand how and why the brain  works the way it does and there's a  beautiful and often challenging thing  about working with code in this way just  like in the best video games the main  limit to what i can create is my own  imagination  [Music]